[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm mark austin live
in la viv in ukraine coming up a
maternity hospital is hit by a russian
airstrike in mariopol during what was
supposed to be a ceasefire
the ukrainian president says children
are buried underneath the rubble and
calls on nato to close the skies
more than 1 200 people are said to have
died in the city with the red cross
describing conditions as apocalyptic
also coming up
[Music]
here in la viv funerals for ukrainian
soldiers as the uk
pledges more military support
and we hear from the people of moscow as
the kremlin says the us has declared
economic war
on russia
[Music]
good evening from la viv in the west of
ukraine president vladimir zelinsky has
again urged nato to establish a no-fly
zone after tweeting that children have
been buried under the rubble of a
maternity hospital destroyed by a
russian airstrike in the southern city
of mariopol the attack came during what
was supposed to be a 12-hour ceasefire
to allow civilians to leave that city
where more than 1 200 civilians are
reported to have been killed so far in
this conflict that pause in fighting
which was intended to establish a number
of humanitarian corridors across the
country has officially come to an end
in the past few minutes
ceasefires were supposed to hold in six
locations across ukraine today to allow
civilians to escape the fighting
but as we've heard attacks have
continued on mario pole and ukrainian
authorities say the airstrike on the
hospital happened during
the agreed ceasefire period
local officials said some civilians have
managed to leave
sumi and enehoda but in isiam the
regional governor says russian shelling
stopped the rescue effort there
no other evacuations happened except for
on the outskirts of the capital where
some civilians managed to escape these
towns via a small bridge in urpin
into the relative safety of the capital
our first report tonight comes from our
security and defense editor deborah
haynes here in lev and a warning it
contains images of those injured in the
attack at the hospital including
children
[Music]
horror and devastation
this was a maternity hospital
terror for babies even before they've
been born
they rushed to take her away
no safety here
ukraine's president said a russian air
strike caused this carnage and children
are under the wreckage
just look at the size of the crater
britain's prime minister called the
attack depraved and said russia's
vladimir putin will be held to account
for his crimes
for mario paul in southern ukraine it's
already a city in ruins after days of
bombardments
perhaps trying to soften its image
russia released what it said was aid
being delivered to another bombarded
city kharkiv in eastern ukraine
the kremlin also claimed without
evidence its military operation had
uncovered a ukrainian biological weapons
programme i knew that they were carried
out by kiev
and financed by the united states of
america
but information or disinformation is as
much of a weapon in this war as tanks
and troops and ukraine strongly denied
the allegation
far away from the front line the other
unmistakable sound of war
three ukrainian soldiers killed on
different days
remembered together
[Music]
and deborah joins me now deborah is
russia saying anything at all about this
attack on the hospital
we've not heard anything yet officially
from russia but it maintains this line
that it's not targeting civilians and
yet the evidence of the ground on the
ground is
painfully the reverse of that and this
attack um on this hospital the fact that
it's um it's been hit whether
deliberately or not
is just a whole new level of horror the
images that are emerging from there are
really hard to to look at even to think
about
the idea of heavily pregnant women about
to give birth and instead being injured
or worse uh in the explosion and just
looking at those pictures the size of
the crater um that was caused by
whatever hit the hospital
is again underlining the kind of weapons
that russia is suspected of using
large-scale bombs missiles launched into
these cities and the uk's ministry of
defense has actually this evening
also tweeted about the kind of weapons
that russia is using saying that russia
itself has said it's using a certain
weapon system that can launch
thermobaric rockets um now you and i
have talked about them before they're
the kind of incredibly indiscriminate
weapon that um sucks oxygen out of the
atmosphere uses the oxygen to generate a
higher temperature explosion that lasts
for longer causing even more damage the
fact that the weapon system that russia
is using here on the ground includes
that again
really counters this argument that
russia is making that this operation
it's conducting is only going after
military targets because using
indiscriminate weapons like that means
you cannot be sure of what is going to
be at the receiving end of what you're
firing
yeah okay deborah thank you very much
indeed well taking over the city of
odessa
also in the south of this country is
seen as one of russia's next strategic
goals
along with mario pole it's key to
russia's plan to create a land bridge in
southern ukraine between crimea and the
donbass region both controlled by russia
or its proxies since 2014. odessa is
home to ukraine's main black sea port
and is crucial
to the nation's economy sky's mark stone
is there tonight and told us what it's
like in the city now
odessa is is ukraine's third city it is
a a key prize for vladimir putin and it
is a a vital sea port the gateway to the
black sea it is quite clear
strategically why vladimir putin would
want to get his hands on this place and
they are well aware of that here there
is a very tense security situation here
i've just been watching from the balcony
where we are the police stopping cars
because a curfew is an hour old now uh
checking uh cars people coming out
they're being frisked outside of their
vehicles uh they are they are tense
there's no question about that many
people have decided already to leave
odessa as we approached uh from
neighboring moldova we saw a growing
number of refugees who have already
passed into moldova and many along the
roads leading uh to
leading west out of ukraine many though
have decided that they will stay some
states will stay to fight some are are
too old too frail to be able to move
and so they will hunker down here a very
very difficult situation for the people
here the russian military are about 100
or so miles to the east of here
in another city where they have been
making gains over the course of today
and of course the russian navy is out in
the black sea as well so there are
concerns
of a of a pincer attack effectively from
the east uh from the the ground that the
russians already hold and an amphibious
assault from the black sea as well
although it must be said that at the
moment uh the americans who are
monitoring uh movements of russian
troops say that there is no sense right
now immediately that an amphibious
assault
is being prepared but as we have seen
that could change and it could change
quite fast
mark stone there well more and more
multinational companies are pulling out
of russia with coca-cola pepsi and
mcdonald's all joining them
since yesterday meanwhile the ruble has
collapsed as the economic sanctions
imposed in protest at putin's war begin
to bite five days since a new law
clamped down on reporting from inside
russia sky's diana magnay reports on the
effect that the war is having on
muscovites
last orders for a big mac and fries in
moscow
when the golden arches opened on this
spot in 1990 there were queues around
the block it was a symbol of glasnost or
opening up as the soviet union came to
an end
my father and my mother was here
at the open uh
these first mcdonald's wow
what did they what did they tell you
about it
they tell that it was
very
crowded but the food but the food was
very amazing because it's something new
for them
now as sanctions close in on the russian
economy it's shutting its doors
mcdonnell says it wants to just pause
operations and that it'll keep paying
its 62 000 staff here but as most
foreign companies pack up and go one
member of the ruling party has warned
that the state should nationalize
foreign assets a retaliatory measure he
calls it in accordance with the laws of
war which by the way is a word that has
been banned in relation to what russia
is doing in ukraine
because if on state media what russia is
doing in ukraine is known only as a
special military operation what the west
is doing to russia putin calls an
economic war
fast food fast clothes apple iphones you
name it they'll be gone
the ruble down almost 40 this year not
further by the u.s and british ban on
russian oil imports
moscow's streets now packed with police
state-run radio sputnik today took over
the frequency of russia's last
independent radio station echo moscow
set up in 1990 just like mcdonald's echo
moscow was also an icon of the
post-soviet era
we visited last week its final day in
existence
shut down for refusing to comply with
new legislation about what you can and
cannot say on air
sergey buntman was its founding editor
we are
professional journalists
and we don't want to make propaganda or
anti-propaganda something like like this
but we want to to uh
to learn facts and to transmit facts
opinions
he tells me his family came from kersen
the first ukrainian city to fall to
russian forces
and when i recognize all the streets
of her son now occupied by the russian
troops
i can remember
by my parents and grandparents
that christian it's a fifth or seventh
occupation of that
poor city of herzone for example
but the narrative told in russia is one
of liberation not occupation a military
operation to bring peace
[Music]
the last vestiges of independent russian
media have now left the airwaves
broadcasting as they did another symbol
from savvy at times swan lake
always aired on soviet tv to buy time
when a seismic event was happening and
that's certainly the case now
dana magnay sky news moscow
well the u.s secretary of state has once
again ruled out a no-fly zone above this
country in a news conference with the uk
foreign secretary liz truss anthony
blinken said an escalation caused by
direct combat with russia could make
conflict even deadlier
introducing in our case uh american
service members
in ukraine on ukrainian territory or
soil
or american pilots
into ukrainian airspace whether on a
full or on a limited basis
would almost certainly lead to direct
conflict between the united states
between nato
and russia and that would expand the
conflict i'm absolutely convinced that
putin will fail
and russia will
suffer a strategic defeat no matter what
short-term tactical gains it may make
in ukraine
let's go live then to washington and
sky's sally lockwood and sally did
anything significant come out of the
meeting between these two
not really mark they presented a united
front and vowed to extend more tough
sanctions against vladimir putin and the
kremlin
but the uncomfortable truth is that
everything that has been done by the
west so far has not deterred vladimir
putin's invasion of ukraine and it's not
stopped
at the bloodshed of innocent ukrainians
uh that press conference came shortly
after the news broke that that maternity
hospital in mariopol
had been bombed and both the foreign
secretary and the secretary of state
were asked about it liz trust describing
it as abhorrent reckless and appalling
and anthony blinken saying that the goal
is to end this aggression and save lives
but we also have to see that this war
does not expand and by introducing u.s
service members on ukrainian soil or
american pilots into ukrainian airspace
that would certainly lead to direct
conflict between the us nato and russia
which of course is at the heart of this
this is the biggest problem the u.s the
uk and nato allies face is how to help
ukraine without becoming direct
participants in this war and of course
we saw that play out and it's continuing
to play out with that offer of polish
mig-29 fast jets to help ukraine poland
uh offering those yesterday announcing
it without any warning to washington
that they would give jets to a u.s nato
air base in germany for them to then
pass on to
ukraine well that was rejected by the
pentagon john kirby the pentagon spokes
spokesman saying it wasn't tenable
and that it's not clear the rationale
for this move well the rationale is that
is is the same for nato and the us which
is that they don't want to be seen to be
giving these jets directly to ukraine
because of course they're nervous that
that would be viewed by vladimir putin
as direct involvement they would become
participants in the war and could
potentially face severe consequences now
anthony blinken also touched on that
saying there are complexities when it
comes to providing this
additional security assistance we
understand
the pentagon continues to talk to poland
about this potential deal when it comes
to offering air support but it's
certainly something that is proving
problematic and in the meantime uh
president zielenski of course is calling
for this air support which still hasn't
arrived and they are still facing these
nightly bombardments uh from russian
missiles uh just one last thing to
mention is that anthony blinken did say
on on president
putin that every time there's been an
opportunity for an off-ramp he's pressed
the accelerator i'm convinced that putin
will fail
that said they don't know how long this
is going to take for vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine to fail and in the
meantime of course the bloodshed
continues and this war potentially could
escalate yet further
yep okay sally thank you very much
indeed
and just to let you know that we're
running a special program this evening
looking at president putin's invasion
strategy
that's putin's war the battle for
ukraine tonight at 9 30 here on sky news
and uh
sorry about that as the fighting
continues in ukraine the refugee crisis
uh deepens here
the un refugee agency says uh that
nearly 2.2 million people have now fled
ukraine of those
uh nearly 1.3 million have crossed into
poland more than 200 000 have gone to
hungary which has changed its
earlier hard-line policy on accepting
refugees
more than 150 000
have crossed into slovakia more than 85
000 ukrainian residents are now
in romania and there is a similar number
in moldova it's also important to note
that huge numbers have already passed
through
after arriving in these countries more
than 230 000 people are now
in other
european countries
well boris johnson says he expects the
number of visas issued to ukrainians
fleeing the violence to rise to the
hundreds of thousands the government has
set up two
special visa schemes open to ukrainians
looking to seek refuge in the uk
the ukraine family scheme allows family
members of british nationals to come and
stay in the uk and the local sponsorship
scheme allows communities private
sponsors and organizations to bring
those forced to leave ukraine to the uk
it's been revealed that 957 uk visas
have been granted so far whilst over 22
000 applications have been made
but how the visas are processed and the
time it takes for them to be approved
looks to be just one of the issues
facing ukrainian refugees looking to
come to the uk skies laura bundock
reports from lille in northern france
anatoly and natalya left everything
behind
except their most precious possession
your baby
natalia is 14 weeks pregnant
the day after this scan putin invaded
and she fled
they've applied for british visas but
won't hear for five days
we have
[Music]
i hope
that very
will be good will be
uh
will i i
get a visa yes
but
i don't know i don't know are you
worried
yes yes are you worried
tetiana is also worried and waiting
we did application application is really
hard because you need to do it for each
of us separately so if you have in
family eight kids or eight people you
need to do application for everyone and
it takes hours
while we were speaking a ukrainian man
comes over nothing here
nothing no he's deaf confused and needs
help
the whole situation is utterly
overwhelming
it's too hard
oh wait
because i've been there
can i
i can't
i traveled all those places and
they are gone
the government says hundreds of
thousands of visas will be issued the
prime minister the deputy prime minister
the home secretary are directly
descended mr speaker from refugees
and we understand we understand how much
refugees have to give to this country
and we understand how much this country
has to gain from welcoming refugees and
we will be generous and we are being
generous but it doesn't feel generous to
muhammad countless train journeys
through europe seem easy when facing
british visa bureaucracy
if they want to go give us like easy
fees i can do it
yes i respect them rules
aspect of things but at least they give
us this visa as fast as they can
the home office is starting a pop-up
visa center here in lille but it won't
offer appointments or walk-ins it's for
ukrainians who are the most vulnerable
but how that's determined isn't clear
coaches are taking ukrainians to lille
long journeys continue
final destinations still unknown laura
bundock sky news leo
let's go live to westminster and our
chief political correspondent john craig
and john so the government's still under
quite considerable pressure over this
that pressure has been going on all week
and mark starting on monday when the
home secretary was bitterly criticized
at the start of a debate on economic
sanctions
on
against russian
russian oligarchs the economic crime
bill then yesterday a junior minister
was dragged to the house because
of the more concerns and
tory mps really vented their fury it was
uh noticeable that it was tory mps who
were the most angry uh the failings of
the home office and today
prime minister's questions you heard
there that was boris johnson responding
to questions from the smp's westminster
leader ian blackford it was also raised
by sarah davey the lib dem leader but
there was a conservative mp uh julian
smith who used to be chief whip and
northern ireland secretary who
criticized the tone of the government's
uh statements on that refugees and there
is still real concern those numbers of
just under uh a thousand uh getting
their visas um is still critics claim
far below what other countries are
getting uh are processing despite the
prime minister saying that the uk's
record is much better today as well as
fierce criticism from mps in the commons
um
there was a bitter attack on the
government's record from the ombudsman
and that's the whitehall watchdog that
uh investigates mal administration as it
calls it in whitehall and the ombudsman
rob behrens has talked about how
about how
this in this horrendous situation swift
actions needed to make sure the process
of getting a visa is simple accessible
and quick and he says lives depend on it
well that is uh backed by many many
conservative mps as well as opposition
mps
all right john thank you very much
indeed and by the way the war in ukraine
will of course dominate tomorrow's
newspapers we'll have our extended press
preview and a
news review from 10 30 this evening
with tonight's news and tomorrow's
headlines
uh joining us will be the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor
of the daily mirror
that is kevin mcguire
right you're watching uh sky news coming
up
two weeks since vladimir putin launched
his so-called special military operation
in this country we'll bring you the
latest on the situation here on the
ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
police have just made their first move
and they've come in firing together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
[Music]
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along all the way we take
you to the heart of the stories that
shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
b
[Music]
well up to now the uk has only sent
defensive weapons to ukraine such as
anti-tank missiles and refused of course
to impose a no-fly zone well today the
defense secretary ben wallace said he
was exploring the possibility of sending
star streak
anti-air missiles they would help
ukraine defend its skies
more effectively mr wallace says he's
confident it wouldn't be
uh classed as an offensive move against
russia
to date the international community has
donated over 900 man portable air
defense missiles
and thousands of anti-tank guided
weapons of varying types as well as
various small arms
but the capability needs strengthening
so in response to ukrainian requests the
government has taken the decision to
explore the donation of star streak high
velocity man portable anti-air missiles
we believe that this system will remain
within the definition of defenses
weapons
but will allow the ukrainian force to
better defend their skies
well the defense secretary also said
russia has changed its tactics and now
uh ukraine has two let's get more on the
situation on the ground thomas moore is
at sky news center
it is now two weeks since russia invaded
ukraine and to give his assessment of
the situation i'm joined by air marshal
edward stringer former director of
operations at the ministry of defense
now
ed that is not the map that president
putin would be hoping to look at two
weeks into the operation
no and as you can see the map really
doesn't appear to have changed that much
um
in the last week
if we look into the south what we can
see here is that long-standing russian
ambition of a land bridge from crimea
which it grabbed in 2014 through the
donbass back into mother russia but also
what it's trying to do
is project forward further into the
black sea and to um and to seize uh
odessa which is the uh is the the major
port
um but what before i go further what i
do want to say is you don't win wars by
seizing all the territory you won't see
this whole map go red there won't be one
soldier in every square yard you do it
by seizing that critical national
infrastructure vital ground and the
centers of national government so
you know if we look in the north what we
can see there is obviously the reveal
plan
is what or was a two to three day opera
operation a lightning operation to seize
the capital to put in a puppet regime to
turn ukraine into a client state and
hope that 44 million ukrainians would
just accept that a heroic assumption
well let's take a closer look at what
this is happening in the north then
first of all of course we have got uh
the the attempts to open up those uh
humanitarian corridors and they did work
in in sumi and in the towns to the uh
west of kiev they didn't work so well
elsewhere unfortunately in ukraine but
you want to talk a little bit more about
what's happening around the capital here
yes one of the bits that has changed is
you know this thrust we see here
from east to west aimed at kiev which we
must assume is directly related to that
convoy that we've been talking about
over the last week the 40 mile convoy
that's come
north to south aimed at kiev but now
looks very much like a self-inflicted
wound that looks like a uh
40-mile roadblock that the russians have
put in on that vital line of
communication so this now looks like the
line of communication they're opening up
on this thrust into kiev but it looks
about two or three times as long as that
one and it's yet another logistic
challenge
for them to solve clearly what they're
looking to do here is put pressure on
that center of government that seat of
government of ukraine in kiev and
position themselves to uh
seize
some form of ground to give them a
better bargaining position to try and
find a political solution
and we
if we take a closer look then at what's
happening in in the air
we know from uh what's happened
overnight was either with the americans
the the offer to uh to
the the migs from poland uh into nato
and then to ukraine the americans didn't
want any part of that but the uk defense
secretary uh has said that the uk will
supply missiles so it's a subtle
difference perhaps
well if you look at what ben wallace's
defense secretary said what did the
missiles he talked about both had an
ante in front of them anti-tank missiles
and anti-air missiles
those are not a problem to you unless
you are yourself offensive and you're
driving tanks towards the ukrainian
defenders or you're flying flying your
aircraft in so they're purely defensive
missiles if there was no attack uh
happening against ukrainian forces then
those defensive weapons have no
offensive purpose hey marshall edward
stringer thank you very much indeed it
is a significant difference for nato
thomas thank you very much you're
watching sky news coming up
poland's plan to provide fighter jets is
dismissed by the us we speak to a former
nato official on the fine line for nato
in supporting the ukrainian forces
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to ukraine let's get more
now on nato's response to the war here
and the
balance that it needs to strike between
supporting the kiev government and
avoiding becoming a participant
in the war the polish plan to provide
ukraine with fighter aircraft has been
rejected for now by the united states
dealing a blow to president silenski
last night the pr pentagon said such a
move was untenable and raised concerns
for the nato alliance well joining me
now is robert pistell a former nato
official and senior fellow at the
casimir pulaski foundation in poland
thank you very much uh for being with us
and good evening uh to you
i just wonder whether i can ask you
first of all
for your comments about this attack
on a hospital in mariopol
well it's it's for the whole world to
see it it's barbaric and but
unfortunately it's it's part of the
pattern you know if you look it's it
does remind one of you know the scenes
we have seen during the so-called first
chechen war okay it was within russia
but still leveling the grossness to one
and we've seen it in syria this is the
way that you know the russian armies
russians harm a trademark they're not
that good uh conducting what we call
proper normal you know
state of military art operations but
unfortunately they are
you know very quick to go and and engage
in indiscriminate bombing i mean this
crater i think it's being shown now it's
you know it came from a one-ton bomb and
that's you know between the maternity
wards and hospital so
it's it's barbaric that's you know and
there's
you know it's growing evidence of
essentially war crimes which uh which
are on the russian uh government's
conscience
what is your sense of where all this
ends how this ends
well i mean various predictions have
been proven around apart from
intelligence
predictions by usc and uk um prior to
this invasion on russian denials you
know
what we have seen is that russians have
not won this yet
and that's due to a large extent to of
course ukrainian incredible harry's an
extremely good organization mobilization
the other reason is
frankly ineptitude combined with
brutality
of the russian military but you know the
calculus is of course not exactly in
ukraine's favor because russia is much
bigger country with huge amount of you
know
arms to bear so the assistance from the
outside world including from nato
countries which of course ukraine has
every right under international law it's
defending itself it's a victim
it's supremely important and that that
assistance apart from sanctions
political support humanitarian support
is is happening and poland is is
actually
if not the key hub for actually
providing this assistance and we've
heard announcements from the uk's
defense secretary just now
so what do you make then of the
americans being what a little bit
lukewarm at the moment on this whole
idea of
putting um
fighter jets into ukraine
well i i mean i would not really
describe it exactly like that i
understand why you are using those terms
but i mean there's been clearly some
kind of perhaps miscommunication but the
facts of the matter are a it's a very
generous offer you know it's over 20
fighter plates
uh offered for free
but you know poland uh you know is is
already if you like at the forefront and
it's it's a good ally and you know uh
nato's unity in this is very important
there's some countries who are in favor
of this not in favor of that or others
are so we need to have a position and on
an issue like this if there are
questions raised about missiles in our
tank and the aircraft surely there are
questions concerning the the fighter
plane so the offer stands
and i've heard uh earlier today for
instance the white house the
spokesperson saying that you know
the logistics are tricky of course they
are i'm sure tomorrow uh the you know
vice president um harris is coming to
warsaw i'm sure she will be discussing
of course the ongoing talks uh between
poland and um and us but also within
later and this is the polish position
the offer has been made but poland
doesn't want to be essentially you know
on out on the limb he wants this to be
properly coordinated
and and then uh on behalf of you know of
a much wider grouping and also us who
has been actually pressing if you like
because ukraine is pressing and we
understand that for a number of days so
you know i hope that uh you know the
most important thing is that ukraine
gets as much help as it can and those
fighter planes could be helpful because
ukrainian pilots know them they are in
pretty you know good condition i
understand so
this is not a spot this is not a quarrel
it's it's a debate because these are
tricky issues and again um you know the
the uk
ben wallace was saying himself that one
needs to strike a careful balance and
was was very careful to say these are
not offensive weapons so of course this
applies to the fight effect so i think
you know poland is in my view not just
because i'm polish is doing the right
thing
uh but it's uh it it wants this to be
properly kind of uh you know coordinated
and done in a as part of a wider setting
because again we need to be united in
this and we need to do things right
again these are the words i think used
by even u.s officials today
right just a minute left but i mean from
what you're saying you think there is
still a way
that this could happen and that the
american objections at the moment could
be
removed
well we we host i mean this i mean again
this is this is about the logistics the
question where should they go first and
so on you know um you know the the the
defense assistance it's literally you
know pouring into ukraine as as we speak
you know i've been drones that's you
know uk actually is you know it's led
the way
uh so
everybody has helped the fighter planes
a bit more complex and that's
understandable so that is again the
reason why uh this issue perhaps you
know has given rise to some perhaps
unnecessary you know miscommunication
that's how we call it but it's the end
effect which matters and i hope very
much this is possible i think ukrainians
are asking for it uh for very very good
reasons
okay robert uh pastel thank you very
much indeed
thank you very much
you're watching sky news live from
ukraine this evening coming up how the
war here and the subsequent sanctions
has impacted on global oil prices and
what people
are paying at the pumps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russia's
soldiers
air raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center of
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
welcome back it's not only the sanctions
that have been imposed on russia that
are driving up global commodity prices
most of the goods that traded from
ukraine passed through the coastal port
of odessa
where we heard from mars stone a little
earlier and with the city under threat
the prices of products like wheat
sunflower oil and
many vital metals are already on the
rise and leading to increased
inflationary pressures
across the world our business
correspondent paul kelso reports
rights have been milling flower in essex
for 150 years but they've rarely seen
anything like the impact of the invasion
of ukraine which has brought russian
tanks to the wheat fields of one of the
world's largest producers in the last
two weeks we've seen wheat prices
increase by more than 30 percent
so
now getting into the regions of 340
pounds a ton which is unheard of we've
never seen wheat prices at that level we
will need very soon to get flower prices
uh increased through into the market
otherwise at these sort of levels mills
will go out of business
in the last month wheat prices have
soared reaching almost 13 a bushel
that's enough for 90 white loaves
wheat is a crucial commodity the source
of 20 percent of the world's protein
this is a global problem that will be
felt at kitchen tables any serious
disruption of production and experts
from the you know from this region from
ukraine from russia
will erode food security for millions of
people around the world you will feel
the impact in the uk you will feel the
impact in many places in europe and
especially in the most vulnerable
countries like the middle east africa
some countries of asia
wheat is not the only commodity under
strain the london metals exchange has
suspended trading in nickel a key
element in stainless steel and electric
car batteries after the price quadrupled
commodities are the golden thread that
run through the global economy or in
this case copper this doncaster firm
makes a million metres of cable a week
and prices are rising even the wooden
drums are made of russian timber there's
a lot of uncertainty with copper
we don't actually know the price of
copper when we're ordering it so we
order in the morning and make a
commitment and if the price is volatile
we end up paying a lot more than what we
thought we're going to pay
in a week 70 tons
10 days ago that cost us about half a
million pounds to buy 70 tons and now
it's over 550 000 pounds
rising prices on the factory floor and
tomorrow's household inflation with
inflation already at a 30-year high the
bank of england was telling us that this
was going to be the sharpest fall in
living standards on record what's
happened is the situation in the ukraine
has made that more intense we'll see a
big squeeze on incomes
across
across the board everyone will feel that
through higher prices and it'll erode
everyone's wages the bank of england had
baked in inflation at seven percent next
month before the invasion the economic
war is triggered means that may just be
the start paul kelso sky news
well as the war in ukraine continues the
price of oil continues to rise
dramatically bringing with it impacts
around the world not least in the uk
where the rac says yesterday saw the
largest ever rise in the average daily
price of diesel we're joining us now is
amy myers jaffe
research professor and managing director
of the climate policy lab at tufts
university thank you very much for being
with us
first of all just put into context for
us how important russia is
as a global oil producer
well you know russia is one of the
largest producers of crude oil in the
world 11 million barrels a day of course
half of that they use for their own
domestic production
but we're talking about exports of five
or six million barrels a day
and
there's a concern that
either through the conflict or because
of sanctions
some portion of that might come off the
market
some analysts are saying that we already
have a disruption of about one and a
half million barrels a day of russian
crude oil just from the fact that
refiners are not buying it or afraid to
buy it um both
for moral reasons and also because they
don't want to get caught up in the legal
complications of sanctions
so how badly do you think this will hit
russia
well you know
it's i mean the crude oil especially
even more than natural gas you're
talking about a hundred and ten billion
dollars a year of of revenues in in like
based on last year
and so it's it's a vital stream of of
finance for the ongoing budget of the
russian government
uh
this
banning uh purchases of russian crude
oil sort of like the last or one of the
bigger
arrows in the quill of financial
sanctions so one has to believe no
matter what governments say it remains a
tool that's on the table
and therefore the question is how do
markets get prepared how do governments
get prepared
what countries are still out there that
might be willing to raise their
production what is the appropriate level
of strategic release of oil stocks in
the eu in the united states and japan
that would be appropriate
we've already seen some releases like
that by the united states
and
also
china has released some of his strategic
stocks so thinking about how to manage
if we get to the point where sanctions
are necessary uh how do you manage
global supply and what are the options
um to
either
get people to use a little less or or to
get squeeze a little bit more supply out
of out of the places that still can do
that
yeah and when it comes to the the ban
for the u.s it's much easier isn't it to
do than for
some european countries well you know
what in the united states effectively
companies had already stopped buying
russian crude you know around the first
of the year
uh we we were already taking a very
small volume as it was so it's really
not
difficult or painful in the united
states
we have a lot of our own production we
have a field in the gulf of mexico
several fields that produce the same
quality of oil as russia so again no
problem there
we have a lot of refining capacity in
the united states so we're not
experiencing
the same diesel shortages that europe
has because europe was very dependent on
diesel exports from russia
so
for europe it's a much more complicated
factor how are you going to
narrow the gap how are you going to cope
with um a cut off
of the use of russian oil if it becomes
necessary
so how how does
a country like germany for instance deal
with this do you think
you know
uh it's gonna take a vast variety of
different kinds of interventions
you know i've seen some statistics about
how much
less heating
energy demand there needs to be if
everybody just turns down their
thermostat one degree but
you know we have a lot of a lot of tools
telecommuting means people are not
having to use their car to the extent
that people are using their cars to go
to work um we have
strategic stocks
you can look at um
in germany you know you have a lot of
homes that have rooftop solar
not
the most productive solar in the world
in the middle of the winter but we're
starting to approach the spring so maybe
some of those homes could be attached to
batteries and that would stretch out um
the availability of the energy to
different parts of the day so i think
there's still you know a lot of
different options of course germany has
announced a very proactive plan for
their long-term energy strategies a very
good plan
but you know we have to get through the
next couple of months is really going to
be the biggest part of the challenge
okay and in just in 20 seconds literally
20 seconds how long will global prices
be
be very high
well i think we're in for a long haul
sadly the
what history has shown us is that when
we have an oil price shock like we're
having today
the solution is the country where the
government or the regions or even the
global economy goes into recession and
that reduces the need for oil and the
price of oil then collapses so if we're
going to follow
uh history
a year from now we'd be we'd be able to
leave it there and oil wouldn't be
needed
got to leave it there
i'm sorry we've got to interrupt you
there this is sky news coming up in the
next hour
we have an exclusive interview with
president zielenski
of ukraine
[Music]
you